♪
>> Jesse: HAS JOE BIDEN FINALLY
LOST FAITH IN HIS V.P. AFTER
KAMALA HARRIS BOTCHED NEARLY
EVERY PROJECT THE PRESIDENT PUT
ON HER PLATE, IT APPEARS THE
WHITE HOUSE P.R. TEAM IS TRYING
TO TURN THE PAGE, PUSH KAMALA
ASIDE AND BEEF UP FIRST LADY
JILL BIDEN WANTS PROFILE.
THEY COORDINATED A NEW PUFF
PIECE PUBLISHED IN VOGUE
MAGAZINE TODAY THAT CLAIMS,
QUOTE.
ROLE DR. BIDEN IS FULFILLING IS
IN MANY WAYS NEITHER FIRST LADY
NOR PROFESSOR BUT A KEY PLAYER
IN HER HUSBAND'S ADMINISTRATION
A WEST WING SURROGATE AND POLICY
ADVOCATE.
COUPLE THIS WITH REPORTS THAT
JILL BIDEN NOT JOE OR KAMALA
WILL BE RELIGION THE U.S. AT THE
TOKYO OLYMPICS.
WE HAVE TO ASK, IS SHE JOE'S NEW
NUMBER TWO?
HERE TO REACT ARE FORMER WHITE
HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY AND HOST
OF OUTNUMBERED KAYLEIGH
McENANY AS WELL AS FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR KARL ROVE.
ALL RIGHT, KARL, I HAVE PICKED
UP ON THIS.
IT DOES LOOK LIKE THEY ARE
TRYING TO PROPEL JILL BIDEN INTO
A MORE SENIOR ROLE AT THE
EXPENSE OF KAMALA HARRIS AND YOU
CAN TELL SHE IS SEETHING IN THE
BACKGROUND.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU PICKED UP ON
A PHOTOGRAPHY LAST WEEK THEY HAD
A BUNCH OF THE PLAYERS IN THAT
BIPARTISAN BUDGET DEAL GO OUT TO
ANNOUNCE OUTSIDE THE WHITE
HOUSE.
KAMALA IS KIND OF LURKING IN THE
BACKGROUND NOT REALLY THERE.
JUST KIND OF LURKING OFF CAMERA.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON.
WHAT'S YOUR ASSESSMENT?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, LOTS OF
FIRST LADIES GET VOGUE ARTICLES
AND, LET'S REMEMBER, THIS IS A
VOGUE ARTICLE.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT NEW YORK
FASHION MAGAZINE SO THEY
GENERALLY DO A NICE STORY ABOUT
THE FIRST LADY.
THEY DO A REALLY NICE STORY
ABOUT THE FIRST LADY IF SHE IS A
DEMOCRATIC FIRST LADY.
>> Jesse: RIGHT.
>> THIS ONE IS OVER THE TOP.
YOU KNOW, JILL BIDEN'S
RELATIONSHIP TO FASHION SEEMS TO
HAVE BEEN COMPLICATED BY THE
PANDEMIC.
SHE LOOKS LIKE A VIRTUAL GODDESS
ANOTHER LINE.
YOU KNOW, THE WAY SHE WAS
RECEIVED HERE WAS BEYOND
TOUCHING.
SECOND OF ALL, THIS WRITER
INJECTS HIMSELF INTO THIS STORY
IN WEIRD, WEIRD WAYS.
ABOUT 75% OF THE WAY THROUGH ALL
OF A SUDDEN I TALKED TO JOE
BIDEN FEW TIMES AND WENT TO THE
BEACH HOUSE IN DELAWARE AND
GRAND KIDS SWIRLING AROUND WHEN
SOMEONE HAND ME A CELL PHONE JOE
WANTS TO TALK TO YOU AND
SUBJECTED TO SEVERAL PARAGRAPHS.
>> Jesse: WHEN I GIVE INTERVIEWS
I ALWAYS INVITE THE REPORTER TO
MY BEACH HOUSE.
KARL, YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT JUST
THAT THOUGH.
KAYLEIGH, IT'S NOW THAT THEY
HAVE THIS PROFILE AND THEY ARE
MAKING HER OUT TO BE SOMETHING
MORE THAN YOUR TRADITIONAL FIRST
LADY LIKE SOME SORT OF POLICY
WONK OR POWER PLAYER AND I JUST
REMEMBER THAT PHOTOGRAPHY WHEN
SHE WAS OVER IN AIR FORCE ONE
FLYING OVER TO EUROPE AND SHE IS
DID HE BIG DESK AND SHE IS
WORKING AND GOT ALL THESE NOTES
WHILE KAMALA IS DOWN IN CENTRAL
AMERICA TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT THE ROOT CAUSES ARE I CAN'T
HELP BUT THINK THERE HAS GOT TO
BE SOME SORT OF JOKEYING FOR
POSITION HERE IN THE HIERARCHY
OF THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> SEEMS THAT WAY.
AN INSIDER TIP THAT PICTURE THAT
WAS TAKEN OF JOE BIDEN ON AIR
FORCE 1, THAT WAS AT THE
PRESIDENT'S DESK.
I CAN TELL YOU THE FIRST LADY
MELANIA TRUMP NEVER SAT AT THE
PRESIDENT'S DESK IN HIS PRIVATE
CABIN.
THAT WAS SHOCKING.
IN THIS ARTICLE, YES, THEY
DESCRIBE HER AS THE DESIGNATED
DRIVER OF THAT TRILLION DOLLARS
COVID RELIEF PLAN.
I DON'T KNOW WHY YOU NEED A
DESIGNATED DRIVER.
WE SHOULD HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO
DOESN'T NEED THAT.
WHO CAN CONTROL IT HIMSELF.
THEY ALSO SAY SHE IS IN CHARGE
OF REIMAGINING EDUCATION,
WHATEVER THAT MEANS.
WE ARE DOING A TON OF
REIMAGINING WELL, YOU ARE RIGHT
KAMALA IS LURKING IN THE
BACKGROUND TRYING TO REMIND JOE
TO BRING UP THE TRAGEDY IN
FLORIDA AT AN EVENT.
HE CLEARLY HAS MULTIPLE
HANDLERS, KAMALA ONE, JILL BIDEN
APPEARS TO BE THE SECOND.
>> Jesse: THEY CALL HER THE
DESIGNATED DRIVER DR. JILL BIDEN
OF THE COVID RELIEF BILL.
>> OF A PORTION OF IT YES, BUT,
STILL.
>> Jesse: WE DON'T WANT TO
DISPARAGE THE PRESIDENT HE IS
OBVIOUSLY THE LEADER OF THE
COUNTRY BUT NOT SO OBVIOUSLY.
BECAUSE OF YOU HAVE SEEN IT HE
EVEN SAYS IT HIMSELF I'M GOING
TO GET IN TROUBLE IF I STAY AND
TALK TO THE REPORTERS.
HE IS OBVIOUSLY HIGHLY SCRIPTED.
HAVE YOU SEEN ANYTHING
OBJECTIVELY THAT CONCERNS YOU
ABOUT HIS ABILITY TO REALLY
FULFILL THE ROLE OF
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF?
>> NO.
BUT THERE IS A DANGER IN THIS
ARTICLE AND IT STARTS WHERE YOU
STARTED THIS WHOLE DISCUSSION.
NAMELY THAT SHE IS A POLICY
ADVISER.
LOOK, THIS IS A DANGER FOR THE
BIDEN WHITE HOUSE.
LET'S SAY THAT YOU WANT TO HAVE
A FULL DISCUSSION OF AN ISSUE,
AND YOU FIGURE OUT THAT JILL
BIDEN IS ON THE OPPOSITE SIDE OF
THE ISSUE, DO YOU REALLY WANT TO
BE THE PERSON IN THE WHITE HOUSE
ARGUING AGAINST WHAT THE FIRST
LADY IS?
>> Jesse: NEVER.
>> THAT'S WHY NANCY REAGAN WAS
SENSITIVE ABOUT THIS.
GO READ WHAT SHE WROTE ABOUT HER
CONCERNS.
BARBARA BUSH WAS CONCERNED ABOUT
IT LAURA BUSH WAS CONCERNED
ABOUT IT.
HILLARY CLINTON WAS NOT.
WHEN I WAS AT THE WHITE HOUSE,
MY OFFICE WAS FORMERLY HER
OFFICE.
SHE WAS THE FIRST FIRST LADY TO
HAVE AN OFFICE IN THE WEST WING
AS OPPOSED TO JUST THE EAST
WING.
SHE HAD TWO OFFICES.
WHEN SHE WANTED TO SEND A
MESSAGE IF THERE IS AN ISSUE
THAT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT, I'M
GOING TO BE IN MY WEST WING
OFFICE, WHICH IS BIG ENOUGH TO
HAVE A CONFERENCE TABLE AND HAVE
12 OR 13 PEOPLE AROUND THE TABLE
SO I CAN BE HEARD WITH WHERE I
WANT TO BE ON THIS.
THAT WAS A PROBLEM FOR THE
CLINTON WHITE HOUSE.
TALK TO PEOPLE THAT WORKED
THERE.
THEY WERE ALWAYS CONCERNED ABOUT
GETTING ON THE WRONG SIDE OF
HILLARY.
IF THIS IS TRUE AND I'M NOT
CERTAIN IT IS, IF IT REALLY IS
TRUE THAT SHE IS A PRESIDENTIAL
ADVISER TAKING THE LEAD ON THE
INFRASTRUCTURE, EDUCATION, AND
PUBLIC POLICY AT LARGE, THAT'S A
PROBLEM.
>> Jesse: MAYBE SHE CAN FIX THE
BORDER CRISIS.
ALL RIGHT, AND I GUESS, GUYS,
THE MOVE, IF YOU WORK AT THIS
WHITE HOUSE, NEVER DISAGREE WITH
THE FIRST LADY.
RIGHT?
>> GOOD ADVICE.